let's go next to our caller from the
three-30 area code who is calling today
from three three zero hi good yes that's
you hi I'm this is mark from mouth
actually Tim Ryan district great what's
going on um I want to ask that's kind of
regards what I'm talk want to ask about
um what do you see like between the news
with how the impeachment turned out what
the DNC manikins at Iowa and predicted
in Nevada and with Bill Barr like
basically getting Roger stone a three
pass like what do you see is like the
matte is like the final breaking point
so the most majority of the public at
this point that's the crazy thing
there's not going to be one that's what
I've been trying to tell people if
you're waiting for the last straw of
trumps interference and dictatorial
authoritarian behavior you're gonna be
waiting forever you're gonna be waiting
through Trump's entire second term
because there is no limit to it and he's
gotten away with everything so far and I
know a lot of people that David Trump
saying you've got to give Roger stone a
shorter sentence this has to be it right
like that
no it's not the the people that are
supporting Trump do not care it's been a
slow but [ __ ] steady slide to
authoritarianism and it's just gonna be
a turnout thing if we can turn out our
side we're not gonna convince any of
them to change their minds they're fully
buttoned it's become cult-like behavior
we've got to get out our side that's the
only way and it is very dangerous to
wait for the thing that will turn the
public against Trump because it's
extraordinarily unlikely to ever happen
if we're waiting for it we'll be waiting
for it until you know 2025 when Trump
leaves office yeah I want to think that
far ahead
right well the reason I brought up Tim
Ryan was because um this area was voted
largely for Trump merely because of
Lordstown GM plant yep but a Tim Ryan
has been like he's been like the Bing
guy here for years like the last
election he was in that he blew the
competition I love water pretty much
everyone I lived here said when he heard
he was running for president like why
would that's it
dumbest thing you possibly hear like
voters clearly don't much think the same
thing I think he never pulled more than
like zero right like that's my thing is
like it's there's a huge Trump base here
and I've been courtesy Bloomberg science
to butts like but they largely most
people largely both Democrat in this
area and it's almost like you know
people here like with Trump's case in
Lordstown I heard what they wanted to
hear and it's like you know it's been
one broken promise after another that's
like I know things like keep I said I
don't feel like it's hot pops ready to
write everybody off because I admit I
have friends are used to me Trump
supporters or some still are my
brother-in-law is it's like but he's a
good guy I know he's not like a Peter
dumbass but oh sure yeah I mean listen
I'm not saying we write off every Trump
supporter I I'm it's just not a strategy
to try to win by convincing Trump is to
change their minds the strategy has to
be get out the vote and mobilize
different communities right because I
have to have my other brother in law
he's not registered my little sister I'm
trying to get her cuz our our deadline
is next Tuesday right I've been trying
to convince them but it's like to them
that's like the bottom of their priority
list they've got their own lives part of
it is pointing out that if people say
well I'm kind of busy trying to you know
fix things that aren't going well in my
life a lot of those things may be fixed
through political solutions if you were
more engaged I think that's an important
point to make obviously not all listen I
appreciate the phone call I hope to hear
from you again let's take a quick break
and we will go right back to the phones
after this if you're holding don't hang
up